owl is in Orlando al how are you I'm
doing well sir are you better than I
deserve what's up so I just started your
program and I'm on baby step 2 and I
have an issue I make about 120,000 a
year but I have about 125,000 beds and I
have a vehicle that is about 910 dollar
payment a month my question is how do I
get out of this what can I do I don't
know I'm just small so this feels I'm
not sure what to do
holy crud 910 dollars what are you
driving dude just a pickup truck is the
Dodge pickup truck okay what in the
world is this thing I mean how did you
is a high interest rate high interest
rate 16 percent
um 73 month payment I've been paying on
it now for about probably two years 29
months
hold on audio on it today what's the
payoff today I believe it's 29,000 it's
worth about 19 okay goodness gracious
mmm-hmm how much is your house payment
ah 1,300 wash your truck payments almost
as I oh yeah I mean if I'm in your shoes
I'm waking up don't don't you wake up
and every time you get in this thing and
start the key on it you wish it would
explode I mean you got to be kicking
yourself like every time you drive it
right yeah it was an absolutely I mean
it was it was a terrible decision yeah I
mean I can make really good money
congratulations
um yeah and really selling this truck is
not going to fix the whole hundred and
twenty thousand dollar problem but it
helps with cash flow so considerably and
I gotta be honest with you if I'm in
your shoes I've done a lot of stupid
stuff out I mean I've done stupid with
steroids I know what it looks like okay
and so when I
or something stupid I don't like to be
reminded of it every day does that make
sense
I brought no God if Dave was in there
I'd be selling it just so I didn't have
to remind me of it every day I mean I'm
not sure it's going to make that big a
difference in your short-term finances
but I just wouldn't want the 16 percent
I feel like I'm being you know I'm being
abused every day which you are and I'm
looking at this thing it's like pointing
stupid arrows at my face every day I
would have to get rid of it for those
two reasons it helps also with the money
because the 910 dollars is going to
clear a lot of debt for you a month
that's $1,000 a month towards your other
stuff if we can get you out of this so
what I'm going to do is run with the
credit union your credits obviously
trashed and see if you can talk them
into borrowing the difference where's
the loan Christ it's at Chrysler credit
yep Craig look I didn't realize I did
subprime stuff like that to that level
Wow okay yeah you got to borrow that 10k
that you're in the hole or you got to
save it up to get rid of it one of the
two so you can get the thing sold
where'd you hear where'd you get the
$19,000 value what is that
I just Kelly Blue Book is that retail or
wholesale that was if I sell to a
private private okay yeah that's
probably your real value then and you
probably rolled some negative into this
too didn't you uh yeah it was about 2
grand yeah yeah good tree granite that
makes sense all right yeah I'm if I can
find the money to cover the difference
that you're in the hole if I'm in your
shoes I'm getting rid of it because I
don't want the reminder I don't want the
16% and I need the 900 bucks clear my
dad it's not like it clears all is only
20% of your dad so it's not doesn't
really fix your debt problem short term
but it does do those three things and so
I am dumping it because it's just the
whole deal is just absurd Wow I'm so
sorry you're facing this ouch ouch ouch
ouch thanks for calling in hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show
down
[Applause]
[Music]